CBS News has confirmed that YouTube is
under federal investigation accused of
illegally collecting data on children
the Federal Trade Commission is leading
the investigation after consumer groups
alleged YouTube exposed children to
inappropriate content and failed to
police videos featuring minors Wired
reported in February about pedophiles
using YouTube's comment sections to
guide other predators to videos of
children the site has since disabled the
comment features under those videos both
YouTube and the FTC declined to comment
when we asked about the FTC
investigation CBS News contributor Nick
Thompson is Wired's editor-in-chief and
he joins us now with more on Nick good
morning good morning
so YouTube would tell you if your kids
are watching you should be supervising
them but back here in the real world
parents use YouTube as a kind of press
play babysitter so they can do other
things yep is it safe for kids to be on
YouTube I think YouTube could be a lot
safer YouTube has a special app YouTube
kids that is much safer there are things
you can do on youtubes you can go into
the settings and turn on restricted mode
that can make youtube more safe and make
it less likely your kids will see
inappropriate videos but the nature of
the Internet the nature of YouTube the
amount of stuff that's on there yes
there are real risks with it how serious
are the complaints against a YouTube
well there's a whole constellation of
complaints so the news right now is that
they illegally collect data on children
under 13 violating federal law that's
what the FTC investigation is about that
is very different from other complaints
that the recommendation algorithm leads
people to see inappropriate things or
that people who have inappropriate
thoughts about children use YouTube as a
way to communicate with each other so
it's kind of three separate issues
coming at the company the one on the
table right now is privacy they're all
serious so let's talk about the the
people that run YouTube Susan Wojcicki
who's very engaged and very on top of
what can if there's a problem Houston I
want to fix it yep so what are they
doing about it what's been their
response Susan is totally on top of it
she Angie has five children she's well
aware of this yeah so what they are
trying to do is they're trying to set up
easier to use preferences for people who
post videos to control the comments on
them they're trying to figure out more
about how the algorithm can be adjusted
so that the recommendation engine makes
it less likely
to lead you to things that are
inappropriate and they're trying to
build AI filters that will more quickly
identify inappropriate content when it's
posted because we're using we're trying
trying trying they're trying yeah it
seems like they're getting better okay
this is a hard problem well I mean when
they really want to yank something down
they can do it fast I try to post a
video with some music in it that was
licensed to somebody and it was I didn't
even get up it just came right down ah
so this is interesting because that's at
the core of YouTube because remember
yeah YouTube's core philosophy is free
speech Silicon Valley is very much a
free speech you know that every let a
thousand flowers bloom let people put
things online YouTube believes that more
than most of the other companies you
listen to Susan she always starts with
free speech she talks about her family
members being librarians so that is
baked into the culture except at the
very beginning the first years of
YouTube they were attacked non-stop over
copyright it would looked like the issue
that would bring it down so they got
really good at that one didn't get good
at the safety stuff your advice for
parents Nick quickly is what watch it be
with your kids when they watch YouTube
not practical right yeah right because
you need the shower now what you want
YouTube for YouTube is there for you to
get 10 minutes to take care of whatever
you need to take care of in the day 10
minutes is okay the recommendation
algorithm is not going to lead anything
anybody to anything terrible in 10
minutes leaving for 30 minutes in front
of the recommendation algorithm whoa
yeah I'll leave it to parents to confess
whether or not 10 minutes an hour 10
minutes is total I'll thank you we
appreciate it